il importe des réponses à quelques
questions et elle faisait les mauvaises
odeurs
d'abord certaines questions certaines
réponses notamment les questions qui se
posaient hier sur la téléphonie ou sur
d'autres choses
il est il n'a pas de réponse sur les
déplacements du véhicule
ce qui reste une inconnue majeure et
puis en l'état les questions vont porter
bien évidemment sur le drap les draps
sur lesquelles nous n'avons aucune
information autre que celle donnée par
le magazine de points je crois sur
lequel on sait que se focalisent
l'attention des enquêteurs
or l adn confirme je suis confiant qu'il
a passé la nuit chez lui ça lui confiant
il maintient rigoureusement sa version
il maintient qu'il a passé la nuit chez
lui
or se pose une véritable difficulté at
il réellement ou pas passer la nuit chez
lui en l'état je suis incapable de vous
affirmer nous de vous confirmer la
version de johnatan les enquêteurs ayant
des éléments sérieux pour bien
évidemment établir le fait que le
véhicule professionnel celui de johnatan
à bouger
parler ça va écouter en l'état il est
dans l'état d'esprit de maintenir ses
déclarations vous savez qu'une garde à
vue ça a évolué on attend les dernières
questions des enquêteurs sur la deuxième
partie d'émission concernant la sphère
des draps qui semble être un élément
majeur
c'est l'élément le dernier élément qui
est attendu dans le cadre de l'audition
garde à vue c'est pas anodin si c'est le
dernier élément je n'ai aucune
information sur les draps en l'état donc
ce drap là pour l'instant pour moi ne me
parle pas
durée de la graine de votre client
dessus je ne sais pas vu ce qui est
annoncé je m'attends à tout je m'attends
l'éventualité qui est son adn auquel cas
ça poserait une profonde difficultés
vous vous rendez bien compte
je m'attends aussi à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas son adn alors est ce que ce sont les
des draps similaires à ceux retrouvés
chez lui je ne sais pas ce qu'on va bien
évidemment nous nous montrer on attend
de voir ce qu'on va nous montrer parce
qu'en l'état
comprenez bien qu'on n'a pas eu accès à
ces pièces là hier il ya beaucoup de
choses qui demandent à être vérifiées
dans les affirmations des enquêteurs y
compris scientifiques techniques
aujourd'hui il est bien évident que cet
argument cette pièce à conviction qu
parenthèses le draw les draps va être
l'élément essentiel du dossier les
échanges ça arrive c'est ont cours sur
les éléments concernant effectivement la
voiture quand les enquêteurs évoquent
effectivement toutes ces pièces à charge
et snoopy est ce que c'est vous qui
maintient ses déclarations qu'elle et
son attitude
john hutton a la même attitude depuis le
départ c'est à dire je n'ai pas
l'explication sur certains points mais
je vous confirme que je ne sais je n'ai
rien à voir dans cette affaire-là
voilà c'est sa position après
moi je vous dirais que je ne sais pas il
ya des inconnues ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'alexia a été tué dans quelles
conditions on ne le sait pas trop où
elle a été tuée on ne sait pas trop qui
est impliqué en l'état on n'en sait rien
toujours est il qu'il ya des éléments
qui sont effectivement gênant concernant
la version de monsieur jo d'athènes
d'aval est ce que le tracker ramène la
voiture jusqu'au bois
cette question là il m'est impossible
d'y répondre parce que tout simplement
je n'ai pas eu les éléments permettant
de corroborer que le véhicule est traqué
jusqu'au bois on a retrouvé à l'excès de
zèle
madame je suis ni sur l'île ni
incertaine son innocence je ne sais pas
je dis simplement que c'est une garde à
vue compliqué qu'on nous a apporté des
éléments qui méritent d'être vérifiés
qui effectivement pose de véritables
questions et je n'atteins n'est pas
soupçonné par hasard c'est une réalité
il ya des éléments sérieux car même les
enquêteurs donc je j'analyse les choses
froidement et en l'état je ne suis pas
là pour dire si jo d'athènes est
coupable ou innocent je me permets de
vous préciser la carte garde à vue sert
à ça aussi que la seule personne qui est
capable aujourd'hui de dire s'il est
coupable ou qui n'osent où il me sens et
lui même et que la garde à vue n'est pas
finie et que de jeunes athènes doit
encore s'exprimer
on est là pour l'assister je ne peux pas
vous dire quelle sera l'issue de cette
garde et l'adn sur les deux versions
quand je suis parti les enquêteurs
allaient aborder la problématique des
dents ils l'ont annoncé
mais ils n'ont pas annoncé c'est une
évidence c'est le dernier point vous
avez remarqué que tout ce qui a était
apparu dans la presse est une réalité ce
problème des draps est une réalité je
connais le dossier
c'est bien
un problème de draka été découverts sur
alexia on va voilà la perquisition
d'hyères n'a pas été fait pour rien des
recherches ont été effectuées et les
questions vont se poser à l'heure
actuelle je vous parle des questions
sont en train de se poser c'est une
évidence
et si les draps l'accablent ce qu'ils
pourraient changer de version mais c'est
le propre d'une garde à vue
effectivement de d'avoir une évolution
dans le cadre de ses dépositions
il n'a à aucun moment en tout cas par
les gendarmes était fait état de
résultats adn sur les draps à aucun
moment il est beaucoup plus dure sur une
chose c'est de dire qu'il n'a rien fait
à alexia que s'est il passé en réalité
je ne sais pas encore
c'est trop tôt mais lui dit quoi qu'il
se soit passé moi je n'ai rien fait
alexis